it's seven o'clock this is sky news
breakfast these are our top stories this
morning
racing to stop the spread concern grows
about the new cloverd variant as british
nationals in southern africa rush to get
home
very emotional
i was happy to see my family but i want
to get home to my husband and my kids
now
yeah so
i hope i can make this flight
a man's killed in northern ireland and
tens of thousands of homes are left
without power in scotland
a storm irwin sweeps across the uk
channel tragedy the family of a 24 year
old iraqi kurd who died while trying to
join her fiance in britain warn others
against undertaking the journey
the sky news hears from those who are
still willing to risk their lives to
cross the channel
yes i
this my family going to uk
[Music]
the man who reinvented the musical
tributes to stephen sondheim he's died
at the age of 91.
and as according to we'll take a look at
the papers with journalists thomas
copeland and effia adam
[Music]
hello good morning welcome to sky news
breakfast thank you for your company
this morning now the world is scrambling
to prevent the spread of a new covert
variance first detected in south africa
a number of countries including the uk
have banned travel from southern africa
leaving many stranded but some
epidemiologists have warned that the
curbs may be too late to stop omicron
from circulating globally or the heavily
mutated and fast-spreading variants has
now been detected in europe and
researchers worry it could pose a threat
to the effectiveness of vaccines either
bennett has this report
at johannesburg's biggest airport an
exodus has begun as british tourists and
dual nationals scramble to get home
very emotional
i was happy to see my family but i want
to get home to my husband and my kids
now
yeah so
i hope i can make this fly
but as travel bans kick in flights are
harder to find many now feel stranded i
must say i had a good cry last night
shays in cape town visiting family and
is trying to get home to some albans it
leaves me with very very limited options
to actually get back um at the moment
i'm looking at flying by a zanzibar uh
that seems to be the only country that
um you know i could possibly get back
from without paying
the 2 250 pounds that the uk is
demanding for quarantine it's just three
days since south africa first reported
the new strain named omicron by the
world health organization and declared a
variant of concern due to its multiple
mutations around the world scientists
are racing to answer the key questions
is it more infectious will it evade our
vaccines
the sensible thing at this stage is to
be precautionary uh and then uh for us
if if things look as if they're less bad
than uh
currently they might be uh then we can
ease back but it makes sense to take
precautions early on uh and in
particular take precautions to slow down
the arrival of this in the uk
for now at least in britain it's
business as usual but with belgium
reporting the first case of the variant
in europe some scientists believe covid
restrictions should be tightened up if
it's already been identified say in
belgium you can't rely on country of
origin um of traveler origin we think we
have to assume
that people can pick it up and so
everybody should be doing pcr tests i
think we should consider
reinstituting isolation on return from
international travel in general
both pfizer and novovacks have said
they've started work on new vaccines to
target the variant already it seems they
can't come soon enough iva bennett sky
news
well this is what we know about the
variance spread so far omicron was first
spotted in botswana on the 11th of
november south africa has confirmed
around 100 cases mainly concentrated in
a country's economic hub the variant has
also been found in hong kong israel and
belgium
many countries have moved to ban travel
from southern africa
the u.s canada brazil and australia have
all announced immediate or planned
travel bans from multiple countries
across southern africa
european union states have also agreed
to suspend travel other countries that
have restricted flights include the eu
uea singapore and hong kong south africa
has called the ban unjustified
well let's bring in our political
correspondence rob powell who joins us
now and rob country's being quick to act
but not everyone is happy about this
move
wasn't there yet um and suggesting that
that might have been something of an
overreaction i think south africa as
well uh maybe feels like it's being
penalized for its own transparency it's
got a pretty good system um for picking
up variants like this and because it has
been open it's now been hit with all of
these um restrictions but i think this
is the precautionary principle um at
play certainly for the uk government
they don't want to be accused again of
being slow to put restrictions um on
worrying variants after what we saw
happened with the delta variant that was
first identified
in india but i think it's important to
remember that travel restrictions and
bans don't necessarily
stop
variants like this coming into the
country they just slow it down so i
think part of the aim here will be if
this is going to cause an increase in
infections in the uk and other countries
to try and push that further
into the new year past the festive
period
to a point hopefully where the nhs is
not going through its traditional winter
pressures it's also about trying to buy
time
as well partly to do those
investigations to figure out whether
this is actually a threat or whether
this will just sort of fizzle away and
fade away like say the beta variant did
and never really took hold outside of um
south africa
it's also though about buying time if
needed to take other action um to
mitigate um against any increase in
infections obviously in the long term
that will be adapting the vaccine
in the short term though i think the
government
here anyway is relying on the booster
program pressure from labour overnight
to
minim to bring down that gap between the
second and third shots to five months
from six months may well be pressure as
well for clarity on whether under 40s
will be getting that in terms of
restrictions the government at the
moment says there's no reason to
divert from their plan a at the moment
so they don't see any need for any more
um domestic restrictions although
interestingly england's chief medical
officer chris whittie at an event
yesterday did say that his biggest worry
at the moment was whether if they needed
to bring back in measures bring back in
restrictions the public would comply at
this late stage after two years
of living through this i think
four weeks to the day until christmas
day that will be a worrying message for
some
robin westminster thank you
well it speaks to someone who's trying
to get back to the uk and that's laverne
fagetti a jewel british south african
national who's in cape town this morning
laverne thank you so much indeed for
your time on sky news this morning and i
know that you've had a tough year of
travel you couldn't go to your sister's
funeral in june and that's because south
africa was on the red list at the time
and now you're stuck in the same
position that you tried to avoid
yes correct
correct
i made the decision back in june because
i've got a toddler
and the whole process of quarantining
with her you know hotel room for 10 days
um was just impossible um i came down
for her
first heavenly birthday which was
yesterday and
obviously waking i'm going to be a
thursday night looking at the headlines
it just ruined the whole day yesterday
as well as today and obviously going
forward
do you know what's going to happen in
terms of you coming back home to the uk
what are the plans when will you be back
i've got no idea um up until last night
six o'clock
my flight was scheduled to depart
on time tonight at six o'clock
um and then i received the text message
um to say that it's now been cancelled
um
that was at a time while my husband back
in the uk
and myself trying to
sort out
both the um hotel quarantining and the
pcr case
um and literally just as we were about
to confirm these things i received the
text message to say that my flight
designed
cancelled
oh my goodness so i mean in in terms of
work then are they understanding this i
mean there's nothing you can do what
you know what what's what have you said
to to work for example
i think i've lost signal
oh i was just i was just saying it's
just you know have you had any
discussions at all with your workplace
because i imagine obviously there will
be going forward to you coming back and
then you cannot help it can you
no
um
yeah i i i haven't thought about i
haven't even thought about informing my
workplace
my main um
concern was trying to get back because
i've got two older kids back in the uk
um
and the decision to leave them back
while i traveled for the special trip
was hard enough and now to face the
possibility of not knowing when i'm
going to see them it's just
it's numbing
and do you have your two-year-old with
you as well your daughter's with you as
well isn't she
yes i have my daughter with me and my
two older boys are with my husband back
in the uk
and tell us about the costs then that
you're now having to face we have the
pcr test don't we and if you do manage
to come in and come back home then of
course you have to quarantine as well
correct um i think when i looked at it
um
around it up to about two two and a half
thousand pounds
um obviously that stress of trying to
the trip in itself coming year was a
costly um
trip and they're not trying to gather
all that money um
i don't even know how my husband and i
managed to raise it with the help of
family um and yeah it's just
it's gonna set us back for probably a
year
my goodness and obviously you're there
at the moment so you're able to witness
and see for yourself how the country is
reacting what are the officials um doing
at the moment
um
i think at the moment yesterday everyone
woke up to the to that news and there
wasn't a lot of information uh trying to
get a pcr test or going to the airport
to get information everyone was just
falling over their feet because it okay
came out of nowhere so trying to find
information was just impossible you're
just sitting and waiting constantly on
facebook groups trying to find out
information so we no one knows nothing
um at this moment in time
laverne forgetty thank you very much
indeed for your time and laverne really
wishing you all the best and i hope that
you and your daughter can get back home
safely soon
thank you very much
well so far no cases of the omicron
variant have been detected here in the
uk but infections are rising 50 000 and
91 new cases of covert 19 were recorded
in the past 24 hours that's nearly 10
000 more than the previous day
and the highest daily figure for nearly
a month
another 160 people have died which means
that the total number of people who've
died within 28 days of a positive test
is 144
593.
23
579 people received their first dose of
a vaccine while 22
823 people received their second dose
and night 396
081 people received their third dose and
booster
now the omicron variant is already
causing concern in the united states
with new york governors declaring a
precautionary disaster emergencies will
come into force next friday ahead of an
expected surge in cases over the winter
the governor added that no cases of the
variant have so far been detected in the
state but said officials were closely
monitoring the situation
in other news a man has been killed in
county antrim in northern ireland when
his car was hit by a falling tree as the
first named storm of the season batters
parts of britain
storm irwin prompted a red weather
warning from the met office which has
now been replaced by amber and yellow
warnings for wind
in scotland the storm has left tens of
thousands of homes without power with
people being advised to travel only if
it's absolutely necessary
storm owen has also been wreaking havoc
in blackpool high winds caused stands to
be blown up onto the roads with warnings
of unsafe driving conditions
blackpool council said roads have been
closed after the collapse of a building
in a tweet it said a building has
collapsed on the springfield road and
promenade junction road closures are in
place in the area and around the area
too please avoid the area at all if
possible diversions will be in place the
tramway is not running and the police
and fire services are in attendance
junction 22 of the m-62 motorway between
rochdale and huddersfield was also
closed in the early hours of this
morning and that's due to heavy snow
caused by the storm look at that
the northwest motorway police have
tweeted to say that the snowplows have
been deployed to clear the road
the first of the victims of the channel
disaster this week has been named
mariam nuri ahmed armen hoped to cross
the channel to join her fiance in the uk
24 year old iraqi kurds she had traveled
from northern iraq to germany and then
to france her family is said to be
totally devastated
well it's the roots of death but i have
to take it that's the words of an iraqi
man who spoke to sky news as he waited
in a camp in northern france to attempt
a crossing of the channel
we've heard from families with small
children living in makeshift camps and
waiting to make the perilous journey
many of them have been traveling for
weeks now some fleeing persecution by
the taliban in afghanistan they say the
channel crossing is safer than the place
they used to call home
and they want to join the 25
700 people who made it across the water
to the uk
a special correspondence alex hawford
reports now from the camp in grand sin
in northern france
the smallest of people facing the
greatest of risks relying on food from
strangers in a foreign land and her
family's intent on taking her on a
dinghy across the channel
you're not worried about your little one
yeah
why
why
because that is
no money no house no
bad life
about everything
we see mothers and their children
everywhere doing what they can to stay
warm and telling us about the same
dangerous decision
yes yes
yes i i
this my family going to uk
in the water
but it's very dangerous with the
children
humanitarian groups who are helping
argue hard-line government migration
policies don't work and simply encourage
the smuggling networks as british people
we should be proud that people want to
come to the uk that they see as
somewhere that's safe for them to live
and there should be a system place that
allows them to do that a safe and legal
route that allows them to do that
without having to risk their lives
the refugees eagerly use charity
charging points to ring home but also to
connect with smuggling groups who take
their money and arrange the sea passage
yes there are some guys responsible for
that they check the road
if everything is safe i mean the police
are not in the road
they manage everything and both
to fix the boat
put everything together many tell us of
several botched attempts but the life
jackets around indicate future channel
trips are still planned a few people
have
built their shelters in the woods
and
quite a few are keeping these on hand
life jackets ready for the next trip
across the channel
among those still planning to make the
trip are unaccompanied children we saw
mostly boys including this 14 year old
seen in the middle of two friends but
who'd fled afghanistan on his own just
before the taliban took power
but this is very dangerous very
dangerous yes
we will die in the sea
but we should go we don't have other way
we found one 22 year old afghan who's
just arrived in dunkirk now desperately
looking for a way to cross to britain
my father's also he was a policeman in
afghanistan so now he is at whom he is
close he cannot go to outside he's
talking to his brother still in kabul
who tells us the whole family's future
rests on him reaching britain safely
[Music]
all those we spoke to told us of
traveling and living rough for weeks
a deal showed us where he his wife and
four young children have been sheltering
the family fled persecution in iraq and
he spent thousands on a smuggling
network openly operating on facebook
again he tells us he has no alternative
of course i'm scared of taking my family
by boat to britain but i've no other
option it's the root of death but i have
to take it
like so many the dangers of making that
terrible journey are eclipsed by the
dangers they're all running from
alex crawford sky news in northern
france
also making the news this morning
here's to the girls who stay smart
aren't they a guest
let's hear it for the ladies
everybody
[Music]
tributes have poured in for the man said
by many to have reinvented the musical
stephen sondheim who's died at the age
of 91.
sondheim was a composer and songwriter
who wrote the lyrics for west side story
sweeney todd company and into the woods
in a career that spanned more than 60
years impressive stuff his work was
performed and lauded by many of
hollywood and broadway's grand danes
including patti lupone audra macdonald
and elaine stritch one of those dames
barbara streitsen has made this
statement overnight she said thank the
lord that sondheim lived to be 91 years
old so he had the time to write such
wonderful music and great lyrics may he
rest in peace
and this message has come from andrew
lloyd webber farewell steve the musical
theater giant of our times an
inspiration not just to two but to three
generations your contribution to theater
will never be equaled
well let's see what storm owen is
causing for us in the weather front
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
that's right storm island continuing to
bring exceptionally strong northerly
winds and some wintry hazards today but
sunday looks calmer and drier there are
multiple met office weather warnings in
force with amber and wind warnings of
gusts in excess of 75 miles per hour for
eastern scotland northeast england and
west wells and south west of england
the world is scrambling to prevent the
spread of a new coveted variant first
detected in south africa a number of
countries including the uk have banned
travel from southern africa but some
epidemiologists have warned that the
curbs may be too late to stop the
omicron from circulating globally well
let's speak now to one of the
specialists who's leading the research
into the new variant and that's dr
richard lesels from the university of
kwazulu natal in durban thank you very
much for your time on sky news this
morning now just looking at the number
of countries were put in south africa on
the red list would you say that the
country is a victim of its own
transparency
yes i think we would and and we've seen
that unfortunately uh before
and and i think what you've seen just in
the past 24 hours is is that these
travel bans
often are ineffective because by the
time you do it the virus has already
actually traveled to to multiple
locations and i expect what we'll see
over the weekend is is that this variant
will will pop up in in many different
parts of the world
and so putting a travel ban
just on the location where it was first
detected has often been shown to be to
be pretty ineffective
i guess from the uk government's point
of view is probably learning lessons
from the delta variant and the
accusations that they were too slow to
stop flights coming in from india
sure and and we understand that of
course but there are other measures that
can be taken and obviously just testing
and and robust testing systems and
quarantine like you saw in hong kong
where they were able to to detect this
variant very early i think what upset us
most in south africa or upset me
particularly it was not not the travel
ban in itself but the fact that it was
announced as the as the single uh
important thing and and that there
wasn't at the same time uh
a pledge of support to southern africa
to south africa botswana and the region
and and and support to really help us
with the public health measures to to
tackle this pandemic and and by that i i
mean predominantly to deliver on these
pledges around delivering vaccines to
africa
how worrying is this new variant in
terms of transmissibility
so as as you've heard
because we detected it quite early again
there's a lot of uncertainties about it
but but what we're seeing is that it's
spreading pretty easily and efficiently
in a population that we think has quite
high levels of immunity to
to the to the virus and and that's
either from vaccination or from prior
infection
and so what we're trying to understand
is what what are the properties
of this variant that allow it to do that
is it predominantly that it has found
new ways to get around the immunity the
immune response
or is it is it just even more
transmissible than than some of the
other variants we've seen so we'll only
really be able to unpick that over the
next few days and weeks as we see what
happens with the spread of this variant
and what we're hearing also is the fact
that it has the potential then to evade
vaccine immunity how quickly then can
scientists adapt the current vaccines
that we have
well you may have seen that that
even overnight most of the vaccine
companies have announced they've already
started work on that modern and pfizer
and novo vax have already started
developing
the changes to the to the vaccine in
case that is needed
what's key here is to is to just always
differentiate between the protection
that vaccines offer against infection
and the protection they offer against
severe disease and hospitalization and
death and what we've seen so far in this
pandemic is that the protection against
severe disease and death holds up very
well
against these variants and much better
than than the protection against
infection
and and and again we will see how
what the data tells us here uh in terms
of whether we see any uh increase in
cases of severe disease and
hospitalization
in people who've been fully vaccinated
do you think that governments across the
country should be introducing tougher
measures such as going back to the days
of social distancing and also just being
more stringent when it comes to putting
on face masks for example
south africa actually we've we've been
consistent with face masks much much
more consistent than many countries in
in europe and certainly the uk
uh and we've never relaxed the the use
of face masks um but we we have been
going through a period of of more
relaxed restrictions in in terms of
people's ability to move around and mix
and and be in larger gatherings and so
it's very likely that over the weekend
we're going to see
a step up in some of the public health
and social measures again the the
national coronavirus command council is
meeting today and and cabinet tomorrow i
think and so we expect to see
more measures put in but again the
critical thing for for the region and
for africa is really getting vaccines
here this is what we've been warning
about for the past year and
unfortunately much of the world is is
willing to sit by and watch this play
out the the reason these variants are
are emerging is because we've left
africa behind with vaccination and we
really must take this now as the final
signal to do something about that
dr richard lizell is from the university
of kwazulu-natal in durban thanks for
your time
thank you
well with us this morning to review the
newspapers are journalists and
broadcasters effia adam and thomas
copeland and there they are they're
looking absolutely glamorous this
saturday morning thank you very much
indeed to both of you for joining us and
when i say glamorous thomas i do include
you as well so thank you very much
appreciate that
don't feel left
thomas let me kick off um with you
because we're looking at this op-ed that
um gordon brown has written and he's
really talking about the obvious which
he has been
banging on about for quite some time and
it's just a mystery that for some reason
our governments and governments across
the world are just not catching on to
this you know if you're not vaccinating
the people across the continent of
africa it's no surprise that we're
guessing these new variants coming
through
well it's a classic collective action
problem and one that every government
faces which is your public wants you to
vaccinate your own pub you know your own
population first before going elsewhere
and then also every country points to
each other and says oh no well you you
give away the vaccines first nobody
wants to be the country that's giving
away vaccines while others free right
off you know your ability to do so if
you've seen brian in the media over the
last couple of certainly the last year
he will undoubtedly have been talking
about this issue of vaccine sharing and
essentially with this new south african
variant he's been proved fairly right
his argument is essentially that
nine billion vaccines have already been
manufactured another 12 by the end of
the year and what he calls quote un-arms
race could have been won here if you
look at vaccination rates across africa
zimbabwe they're down 19
and namibia 14 south africa lesotho in
around 25 27. so it's not a production
issue you know because we're producing
enough vaccines it's a distribution
issue and you just had an expert on
there from south africa who was
commenting on exactly this issue to do
with distribution if you look at i mean
think back to it was only september when
we had g7 and you had major countries
and economies from around the world not
just the g7 there were
you know south korea australia
india i think were invited to that as
well made commitments about how much
they would give
to developing countries around the world
and if you look at sort of the extent to
which they've matched those commitments
so far
they're paltry i mean america to be fair
is up and around 25
delivered as many vaccines as it said it
would to developing countries uh
european unions 19
uk is 11 calendars as low as 5
you know so
and you've also got this issue of there
are 100 million vaccines in the west
that will be going out of date their use
by date will expire in december and the
likelihood is that there won't be the
distribution infrastructure in place in
order to get those to me to africa or
indeed absorbed in that amount of time
because of because of a lack of of
medical infrastructure in africa so you
know
i suppose
brian's argument has has always been
this is about enlightened self-interest
and this is exactly the situation that
we're stumbling upon if it is the case
that this south african vaccine causes
havoc in the uk lockdowns return to face
masks then he will have been proved
rather right and if anything but you
know i i still don't think the general
public will say oh definitely give
vaccines away you know it's just
it's one of the enlightened
self-interest is a hard argument to make
brian's been making for a long time but
he's not in government absolutely i mean
self-interest hopefully people can then
see beyond you know our own borders and
see that this is a global pandemic and
if the rest of the world are not
vaccinated then guess what we're going
to keep going around in circles so
hopefully people can um look beyond
their own um front doors there uh
let's stick with this story then because
obviously um coveted continues to
dominate especially with a new um
variant that's um popping up and the
guardian here carrying a story about
germany being at crossroads with
prospects of lockdowns covert cases rise
44 in a week
that's right there's been a huge jump in
clover cases um in germany and one a
government minister has said that
they're on the road to chaos and so
one another professor in germany has
also said that they need a massive
reduction in contact immediately to keep
cases down no cases have risen 75
400 so that's more cases in a week which
like we said is a jump of 44
so of 22 000 available intensive care
beds in germany 8 000 of those are taken
up by covered patients 85 of those cova
patients need breathing assistance and
the age range is from 50 to 79. so at
the moment um
cases in germany are spiraling out of
control um no it may not seem like 8 000
uh cover paces in intensive care is is a
lot but it's a hundred percent increase
from last week so it's doubled basically
and yes they're in a a a situation now
where the clever cases are spiraling out
of control a 44 jump in a week is huge
100 jump of people in intensive care is
huge as well and that leads to crippling
infrastructure that leads to health care
services not being able to cope that
leads to staff burnout in healthcare as
well and when your healthcare system is
overwhelmed then you cannot cope with
everything uh routine operations are
being cancelled as well as well in
germany so yes they're calling for a
national lockdown it may happen we don't
know i think they're going to see where
the cases are in a few more days but
like we said a 44 jumping cases in
germany is huge
and um thomas let's just come to this
next story obviously we know what's
happened this week 27 people dying while
trying to cross the channel to the uk
it's just devastating because now we're
getting more details about the people we
can now put faces to the names and the
statistics and
this young woman who was trying to get
to the uk to join her
fiance it's just it
devastating isn't it i mean her husband
her fiance is going to have to
deal with this now
well i mean it's extraordinary when you
quite often is the case and and um not
in a particularly negative way but often
the media contribute to this these
things when you know migrants have died
as opposed to saying you know human
beings people have died this is a 24
year old woman a baron nuri who you know
your whole life is ahead of you and and
you think of the situation into which
she was forced in calais to put her
faith and her trust into a human
trafficker to take her on 27 other
people and a relative of hers across the
channel i cannot imagine the extent of
the devastation that her fiance who's
pictured there as well and is living in
the uk is feeling right now and the
tragedy of course is that you know the
these are these are people who could
have contributed and might have
contributed and almost certainly would
have contributed here in the uk and that
they were put in a situation
and i i sort of i'm not one of these
people who who tries to
you know extort the blame out too far
human traffickers put her in this
situation and i think we need to you
know it's really important to remember
that somebody took advantage of perhaps
her desperation to get here to the uk
the government has a real responsibility
here as well but it's important to
remember that you know there are
criminals who are taking advantage of
these people and so when you start to
see the likes of you know twitter spats
going on between the uk and france you
always need to remember that there are
human beings at the heart of this and
they are not as often depicted about
migrants you know these are people who
have who have
come to the ends of the earth all the
way from kurdistan uh to try to come to
the uk with a whole life ahead of them
and that needs to be you know part of
the story as much as you know another
sort of argument between emmanuel macron
and boris johnson and um
fdr i'll come to you very quickly
because we're running out of time we
keep running out of time we need more
time to spend with you guys but let's
just very quickly talk about strictly
because motzi being forced to
self-isolate it will not be the same
without her
no she won't be on the show this weekend
now this is because um she has been
exposed to cover but and she's been
forced to self-isolate although she's
had in fact i think three vaccinations
she's had now because she's had them in
germany and they aren't recognized in
the united kingdom because of those
cross-border rules and she still has to
self-wisely so she has to self-isolate
until the 30th of november so we'll be
missing from straightly this weekend but
instead cynthia arrivo is going to be in
her place so one fabulous woman replaced
by another well they go then we'll
support them all and love them all thank
you very much indeed